the news of another spike in coronavirus
cases in Italy this weekend kept many
off the streets of Milan a city at the
heart of territory now in lockdown fear
is real here and across huge swathe of
northern Italy worst hit by the virus
after a week when the government
implemented increasingly strict measures
now the Lombardi region and 14 provinces
are sealed off from the rest of the
nation we understand that all these
measures will create inconveniences we
understand that these measures will
impose sacrifices sometimes small and
sometimes very large but this is a time
where we must take responsibility for
ourselves we need to understand that all
of us need to adhere to the measures we
shouldn't think that were more clever
than that in Venice one of the affected
cities tourists were largely absent from
the normally bustling areas all major
gatherings will be halted under the new
restrictions gyms museums ski resorts
ordered to close weddings and funerals
will be stopped as part of the measures
which will last until early april but
the virus is impacting daily life
outside of the lockdown area and masses
in Rome people sat a metre apart from
each other and visitors were thin on the
ground outside the Vatican which has
reported its own case of the virus I am
close in prayer to people who are
suffering because of the current
coronavirus epidemic and to all those
taking care of them there had been
worries for the Pope himself after he
cancelled a retreat because of illness
but the Vatican said he simply had a
common cold the tough new measures are
aimed at preventing coronavirus hitting
other parts of Italy as badly as it has
the north but many Italians are critical
of the government saying they've
introduced restrictions far too late
many attempted to escape the north last
night as news of the ban on movement
leaked out there was a rush for the last
trains out of Milan and other cities and
towns movement in and out of the
affected northern areas is now
restricted except for emergencies and
legitimate health and work reasons and
those still in the region around 16
million people are being told to stay
indoors as much as possible but look as
the Chilean donnell imagine that what is
happening in my city is worrying me and
this is also sad because Milan is a
lively city and to see it like this
today is almost a defeat for me we have
to remain positive and calm and live in
the best way taking all precautions we
have to adapt our lifestyles but we
carry on the government has said anyone
found flouting the ban could face jail
but patrolling the region to ensure
everyone stays put will be another
challenge for a government dealing with
Europe's worst coronavirus crisis
Michelle Clifford Sky News Rome